欢迎今天来参加咱们这场分享会的小伙伴们哈,距离咱们上一次这个分享会呢其实已经过去时间蛮久了,那中间呢当然有很多小伙伴也在问我说,什么时候咱们再来一场就是像之前一样干货非常多的这样的技术分享哈,所以呢今天我又邀请到一鸣老师来为咱们讲,因为很多小伙伴会比较关心套利策略方面的东西,所以呢就邀请到一鸣老师来今天给咱们讲一个区别于咱们目前国内主流的套利策略的一个完全新的一个框架,
来跟大家去聊一聊
好吧
那大家待会儿在听的时候呢
可以记录一下想问的问题
等到一秒是讲完之后呢
我们可以就是到时候直接上麦提问
或是在咱们的评论区提问都是可以的
好吧
那我接下来就把时间先交给一秒老师了
一秒老师
好的有你
然后这个今天咱们讲一个不一样的套利框架
因为之前也有很多小伙伴
然后那个在线下课上完之后呢
然后给我私信
然后就是说有没有可以那个套利的框架或者是方式
然后也是统一回答大家的这个问题
然后我也是专门做了这么几个PPT
然后呢今天是专门的讲一个不一样的套利的一个框架
其实大家可以在咱们原有的这个基础课的这个Pipeline
就是生产线上面稍微改动一下
其实就是完全一套全新的一个套利框架
然后今天我详细的讲一下
今天的几个内容是这样的
第一是我们先了解一下
就是不同的量化策略的第一性原理
也就是说不同策略的
我们到底赚的是市场什么的钱
或者说叫底层逻辑
第二点就是我想表达一下
就是如何突破现有的这种常规的
这种套利的思维
然后第三就是说
我们如何在多品种
多地域多市场的这么一个视角下
来找到这个套利品种的这个机会
对那下面呢
就是这个用机器学习框架来
如何构建套利的策略
那以及呢
我们如何在套利的策略中呢
加入一些产业链的支持
对那最后呢
也就是说我们如何把
整个的拍拍烂串起来
也就是说整个数学逻辑框架下
如何设计一套
就是非常高效的这种
机器学习的套利框架
然后正好借着UNI的这个平台
然后也借着今天的这个主题分享
然后我个人想有一个说明
就是一个声明
想和那个小伙伴讲一下
然后第一是很感谢大家的
一直以来的这个信任
对另外的就是我想说的是
因为我目前的这个国内的课程
是只有线下课程
然后没有线上
对
然后并且只有是在uni这边来组织的
然后除了像我们今天这样的
线上的基础交流分享会以外
就没有任何线上付费课程的内容
对
所以希望大家谨慎的辨别
不要上当
对
这个也是我个人的一个声明
然后咱们继续
然后大家先看一下
这个是我用这个机器学习的方式
其实是基于咱们基础课程的这个type line
然后在设计的一个玻璃和这个纯碱的一个套利的这个策略
那大家可以看一下呢
这个我待会会讲的这个策略
最后的这个是如何来做的
那大家看到这是玻璃和纯碱套利的方式
那我们用的这个deck testing回测呢
是近两年的哈
是2024年的1月2号
截止到上周
也就是说2025年的12月19号的上周五
然后两年的这个测试
然后呢一共是24个月
然后呢总的收益呢是82.23
最大回撤呢是8.99
卡码是在4.58
然后回撤面积呢是21.29
然后我们交易了呢是838次
然后空仓没有交易的时候
是196次
这个是想给大家看一下
就是用我们整个经济学习的pipeline
跑下来套利的模型之后的
这么一个backtesting的这么一个结果
然后我们再逐步的来对这个模型进行拆解
然后我们先一步一步的来
然后我先讲一下
这个就是不同的量化策略的
这个底层逻辑
或者叫做低性原理
也就是说大家要清楚
我们设计很多的这个pipeline
或者叫设计很多的这个模型
那我们究竟是想赚市场怎样的钱
那这五个策略
大家可以看到红色的部分
像趋势策略
均值回归策略
截面策略
套利策略
以及波动率策略
这五个策略
其实是非常主流的
基本上已经占到90%以上的这个市场份额了
那当然说这里面也有没有提到的
像比如说HFT就高频交易
还有一些另类的方式
可能就是在那个不到10%的这个市场占有率
那我们就暂且不提了
对那以这个市场占有率最多的
这个五大策略来讲的话
咱们一个一个来看
那首先趋势策略呢
其实我们是赚的是市场惯性的钱
这个大家可能都会很清楚
那我们的这个趋势策略
其实底层逻辑
其实是价格变化序列
存在这种正的自相关性
那也就是说
我们利用了这种自相关性来转线
对那为什么我要讲
每一个策略的这个底层逻辑呢
其实对我们后面套利策略的设计
其实是至关重要的
对那大家可以看到
这是趋势策略的这个底层逻辑
那均值回归呢
其实是什么呢
均值回归其实是和这个趋势是有联动的
那也就是说
那比如说那我们的一些趋势
无论是上涨还是下跌
那只要它的市场过度的这种趋势发生了
那肯定就是市场会自动的来修正
这种价格与价值的这种偏离
那也就是说我们看到的这个均值回归的底层逻辑
其实是价格与价值的这种偏离的修复
那也就是说我们均值回归赚的
其实是市场过度反应纠正的这个钱
对
那这个今天讲的这个截面
另外呢
就是这个截面策略呢
其实是赚这个相对价值差异的这个钱
那大家也清楚
还能更多的
其实我们会在这个个股
特别是在股票策略上面
经常会用这个截面的策略
那其实他赚的是这个相对价值差异的这个钱
那底层逻辑呢
其实就是我们希望
这个剥离掉这个整个市场的这个Beta
只保留那个Alpha的这个部分
那当然说这个也是基于
最初的这个经典的这个金融理论
那下面呢
其实就是我们今天的重点
就是套利策略
那套利策略呢
其实是有点类似于
均值回归的这个策略
但是还不太一样
那其实它底层逻辑
其实是在赚这个市场
市场摩擦的这个钱
因为大家都清楚
那我们套利策略的时候
那我们可能会算两个
或者是多个这个标的这个价差
那其实价差呢
其实就等于它的理论价差
那加上这种摩擦成本
以及风险溢价
那这个它的价差
是不是从这个均值回归的这个方式
那我们是不是可以用均值回归的这种方式
来做这个价格差的这个交易
那其实也是一些经典的
传统的套利方式常用的一种逻辑
最后就是波动率策略
波动率策略更多的是
出现在期权市场上
比如说我们做期权市场的套利
或者是一些比较另类的
期权的策略
其实主要赚的是
情绪定价
情绪定价偏差的钱
底层逻辑其实就是说
我们对市场对波动率的定价
其实往往是反应过度
或者是反应不足
其实就是赚的定价的偏差
那这么看下来的话
其实大家可以联想一下
其实我们市场上有很多
无论是海外也好
还是国内也好
其实有很多各种各样的策略
其实这些策略
都是源于这五种策略的相互之间的融合
或者叫相互之间的这种组合
可以产生我们更多的策略
大家其实也看到了
我们超利策略
其实是赚的是市场的哪一部分的钱
那这个套利呢
其实也是我们今天的一个重点
那我们了解完之后
套利是在市场上如何来赚钱的之后呢
然后我们看一看就是当下
就是在套利的策略中
有哪些不同的这个技术路线
都可以有哪些方法
那我个人总结呢
其实是有四大类吧
四大类别
对这是比较主流的
那第一个呢
其实就是基于这个
基本面驱动的套利的路线
那比如说
我们会研究产业链的这种平衡
还有季节性的一些套利的方式
那还有呢
就是经典的这种统计套利的路线
那比如说基于协整性的套利
这个当时是用的最多的
那还有一些基于相关性的
这种配对的这种交易
那待会呢
我会每一个策略进行展开
那再往下走呢
其实就是基于一些
这个概率模型套利的技术路线
比如说是基于
这个Copular的这种套利
就是更关注一些
分布的这种状态
对那还有呢
就是基于这个状态概率转移的
套利的这个方式
待会儿每一个再详细的讲
那另外呢就是说
还有我们的今天的重点
就是机器学习的这个
这个套利的这个技术路线
那其实呢
其实它是分两类
那一类呢
是我们可以用机器学习中的这种聚类的方式呢
来寻找到就是常规人工很难找到的这个套利对
对那这个也是机器学习的一个方式
那一个是寻找
那另外呢
一个就是说是用预测加差的方式来进行这个机器学习的技术路线
对那大家可以看到呢
刚才我们也是了解到了
那暴利策略的底层逻辑
其实就是价差
当然说有的小伙伴会习惯用价差
那有的呢
可能习惯用那个价格比
那这个都没关系
逻辑相同
那重点是我们可以对价差
或者是对价比
或者是对一些另类处理的价差价比
进行这个结果的这个预测
重点是可以做这
可以做预测相关的
这个机器学习的模型训练
那我们对每一个
这个技术路线进行展开
我们传统呢
我就一带而过
因为这个可能大家都比较了解
那基本面的呢
主要是两个
那一个是产业链平衡的
那一个就是我们这个
季节性套利的这个模型
对那就是
我就不给大家念了
我就讲那个重点
这个小伙伴
待会可以找这个uni
找这个uni来要咱们的这个PPT
这个PPT都是可以给到大家的
那产业链平衡的
其实它更关注于一些这种物理上的
或者叫产业链
或者叫经济上的这种平衡的这个原理
对那这个基本上的是建立在这个
比如说产业链上下游啊
或者是一些可替代的这种关系
对那比如说我们常见的工业品啊
像农产品都会采用
可以采用这种方式
对那比如说我们计算价差的时候
可以把我们的一些的这个产业链的价值传导
以及路径或者叫转换函数
或者叫转换的系数
然后算到这个我们的这个价差里面来去
那后面的我也会详细讲这个产业链的这个
如何在这个机器学习的这个技术路径里面
加入这个产业链的这种相关的价值传导方式
这个其实就是我们产业链平衡
就是基于产业链平衡模型的套利的
技术路径
每一种技术路径
我总结的就是原理以及实施要点
以及它的优势
以及它的这种局限性
传统的我就不给大家念了
到时候大家可以找优利要PPT
自己可以看一下
实施要点的话
其实我们可以照着这个方式
来进行整个Pipeline的设计
这个是基本面的
基于产业链平衡的模型
第二个基本面其实就是基于这种季节性考虑
它重点其实就是对历史的一些像STL的这种分解
确认这种季节性的模式的统计
比较显著的前提下进行
基本上其实和上一个基于产业链的差不太多
接下来我们看一下经典的基于协整的以及相关性的
这个可能是大家比较常用的
实施的方式我也给大家罗列出来
比如说我们选了两个品种
无论它是有物理连接
还是有统计连接
比如说我们先进行这种协整的检验
如果确定它有这种协整性的话
我们就基于这种协整方程
来构建统计平稳的这种加差序列
无论你是加差也好
还是这种价比也好
那最终呢
我们的交易逻辑呢
是落在这个
那如果我们的这个计算结果
价差比如说超过了
多少倍的这个
标准差的时候
那也就是说证明
它的这个价格上去了
或者是下来
对那我们其实就是在
这个价格序列上
其实是无形当中会计算
两个一个上限一个下限
它到上限的时候
那其实是我们要做空
这个价差
那如果到下限的时候
其实就做多这个价差
那因为我们知道
这个价差会有这种
均值回归的这么一个规律
对
但是呢
这个协整
其实最大的一个问题
就是说
那经常市场会
比如说
因为你算的这个
N倍的这个标准
它其实应该是动态的
那它不应该是死的
对
那也就是说
那你即使是动态的情况下
那它如果超过了
你的上限非常多
或者是超过了你的下限
非常多的时候
也就是说我们尾部风险
负限的时候呢
那其实这种方式是比较危险的
对那比如说那
那我们是止损呢
还是我们在加仓呢
那其实每个团队
有每个团队
不同的这种解决方式
对那它其实最致命的
一个局限呢
其实也就是说是
对这种线性假设的这种限制
那我这边也罗列出来了
那也就是说我们没有办法
只通过这个简单的斜整
或者叫价差的这种标准差的关系
来捕捉到这个
就是标的两个标的之间的
这种非线性的这种关系
它只是一种线性假设的线
那所以呢
那这种方式呢
其实是非常经典的
然后当然说
现在可能大家用的都会比较
那接下来呢
和那差不多的呢
其实就是相关性的这个配对交易
那主要的其实也是基于这个标准化之后的
这个标准差来进行这个套利
那和这个协整性的方式其实差不太多
对
那我们再看一下这个概率的
基于概率的模型的
其实是有两个技术路径的
一个是这个Copular的这个套利的方式
一个是基于这个马尔可夫的这个概率转换的
那这两种方式呢
可能大家也听过
但是我是觉得这两个方式
其实可以和机器学习的方式
进行这种深度的结合
那这个Copular
其实是我们在实施的时候
其实更关注的
其实是它的这种边缘分布的这种礼盒
那也就是说尾部
那比如说我们会选择适合的这种分布
比如说你是正开
P分布还是极值分布等等
那我们Copular的这种选择
也是依赖于这种特征选择的
那比如说是完全高斯的
还是关注T值的
比如说是关注肥美的
对那他的计算呢
也涉及到这个最大四人估计
对或者叫做这个IFM
就是推断估计
然后所以呢
我们它的重点呢
其实是计算这种尾部概率的这种计算
对
但是呢
它其实明显的这种缺陷
也比较有关键的这种局限性
因为我们选择这个popular类型
选择的时候
就是说是一旦我们选错了的话
就是会导致后面我们所有的这个
比如说尾部概率计算
或者叫做我们用的中间过程
一旦出问题的话
其实会导致我们后面的这个
在交易的时候
会产生很大的这个问题
对
当然我个人觉得这个copyler
其实是如果与这个机器学习
来进行结合的
也是未来会非常有发展的
一个套利的技术路线
那还有呢
其实就是基于隐状态的
隐状态大家可能不太
都不太陌生
那如果听过咱们基础课
或者是今天课的小伙伴
对这个引状态一定非常的服役
那其实呢
就是我们利用这种状态的
线路转移
来进行这个标的之间的这个套利
那这个当然说我们也可以用
现有就是说我提到的这个
比如说是这个
比如说基于马尔可夫转换自回归的
这种简称叫MSAR
或者叫MSGATS
这个也都是比较经典的方式
或者是我们直接用银马尔可夫
其实也可以建立
引状态的概率转移
最终其实它的核心
是进行这种异常值的检测
也就是说我们找出这种异常来
只要是异常的时候
我们觉得它可能
就是转移的概率会比较大
比如说我们及时调整
我们的仓位以及方向
但是这个也有一个致命的局限
也就是说它
大家都知道
那隐状态的这个
它其实存在一个最致命的一个问题
就是边界的问题
那我们没有办法计算当前的这个状态
是固于什么状态
对那如果我们能准确计算的话
那其实它本身就可以作为交易策略了
那所以呢
它有它的这种滞后性
对那所以这个也是比较它致命的一个点
对另外呢
就是隐状态的
坦率讲的是缺乏这种解释性的
就是它是数学逻辑是通的
但是这种如果是站在金融
经济的解释性上
稍微会弱一点点
但是这种方式
其实也是给我们提供了
很多的这种思路
大家可以看到
我们刚才提到了
三大类的不同的技术路线
基本面的经典套利的
然后概率模型套利的
然后每一个我列举了两个例子
那大家有没有想过
那既然我们机器学习的技术路线
可以帮我们进行价差的预测
以及同时又可以帮我们找到
我们人工很难察觉到的
一些套利对的这种选择
那其实可不可以
我们把传统的技术路线
和我们现有的这个
机器学习的技术路线相结合
就是也就是说产生一个
我们全新的一个技术框架
那今天呢
这个其实我重点讲的
也是这种结合
那今天呢
因为时间关系呢
我们把这个基于基本面的
就是把这个第一个技术路线
就是基于基本面
其中的基于产业链平衡的模型
对
那也就是说是最基础的
基于产业链平衡的这个模型
与这个我们的机器学习的技术路径进行相结合
那我们看看会产生什么样的惊喜
那首先呢
我先讲一下这个机器学习的这个两个重点
那一个是我们对于配对的标的的选择
那一个是我们这个对价格预测的这个技术路径的原理
要点优势和局限性
那我们先看这个选择
因为这个我们可以
当我们就是在市场上
找到一些这个套利标
就是套利标的的时候呢
基本上其实是我们常用的一种方式
那比如说工业品呢
我们知道这个比如说
这个生猪和玉米它可以套利
那比如说这个铁矿和螺纹可以套利
那黄金和白银
那我们今天的例子呢
是囤碱和这个玻璃
那它具有一定的这种物理
或者是物理关系
也就是说是工业上的关系
或者是农业上的关系
或者是我们这个金融资产
比如说黄金白银
对这些也是没有问题
甚至我们的比如说
我们的加密货币
比如说我们的BTC
与我们的ETH
对那其实也是可以进行套利的
那当然说这个都算是金融资产
对那所以呢
这个在我们图支的这些套利对以外
那有没有套利的机会呢
那其实也是有的哈
那其实我们可以用这种
无监督的这种聚类的算法
对
比如说
做我罗列了三种哈
那当前其实
用的最多的最前沿的
其实就是这个
层次聚类和这个
这个其实在业内用的
都是蛮多的
那也就是说
我们找到了很多这种
奇奇怪怪的这种标的
那我们也不知道
它之间有没有这种
套利的这种关系
对
那么其实我们可以用这种
层次聚类
或者是用低比斯坦的
然后看看他们能不能聚在一起
那假设我们能够聚在一起的话
那其实比如在数
在数学层面上
那其实我们觉得是
可以有这种套利机会的
那这个也是
那当然说它实施起来
也相对比较简单
那比如说我们的特征是基于什么呢
基于比如说这种波动率
自相关性指标等等的一些特征
那我们呢
用什么样的方式呢
其实就是基于这种时间序列的
这种距离的度量
那比如说是我都罗列出来了
比如说动态时间规整的这个DTW
那以及这种相关距离的这种方式等等
那当然说还有很多
其他的这种方式了
对那我们看它可不可以聚在一起
那假设如果是能够聚在一起的话
那其实我们就觉得
它有可能能够产生这种配对的
就是能够产生这种配对的这种方式
对
那我们再进行深入的研究
看看能不能从中找到这个获利的
这种或者叫套利的这个结果出来
那如果结果比较显著的话
那其实即使两者没有什么太相关的关系
那或者是叫我们人类没有能够从直观上
感觉到他的这种关系的情况下
那其实也是可以进行套利的模型的做进
那这个也是现在
就是国际上大家通行的这么一种方式
那这个是我刚才讲到的
就是说用聚类的方式
那进行套利对的这种选择
那在这个基础上呢
那我们机器学习还可以做一些什么呢
其实就是对这个价差的预测
因为这个我们就是讲的比较直接
那机器学习既然能做预测
那是不是我们就可以
那如果你是加差也好
就是或者是价比也好
这个都没关系
那反正我的生产线
我是可以预测的
那从这个角度来讲的话
那是不是我们就可以
针对你的价差或者是价比
进行预测的这种模型的设计
或者叫生产线的设计
那如果我是可以预测的话
那其实我就不用你的
什么传统的这种基于
基于协整的方式啊
或者是基于这个概率转移的方式
或者是这种Copular的这种方式
对那我直接就是用最简单的逻辑
就是我直接就可以预测
你的这个价差的走势
那岂不是就是更简单吗
那所以呢大家可以看到
那假设说我们用机器学习的
这种方式来设计我们的生产线的话
其实就是回归到一个
价差的一个预测的一个问题
那大家可以看看
那比如说我们用这个价差的预测
也就是说我们用机器学习的方式
那我刚才讲到了
那我们可以把我们传统的一些方式
和这个机器学习的方式相结合
那我们今天讲的这个案例
是我们把这个最传统的
基于产业链关系的这种方式
与这个机器学习的方式来结合
那产业链的关系
其实它突出的是什么呢
突出的是我们的价格之间的关系
或者叫物理上的这种关系上的这种环导
那如果是工业品或者是农产品的话
可能我们要看它的这种物理的关系
比如说它是不是上下游
它是不是可替代
对
那如果是金融资产的话
肯定有小伙伴会问
那你工业品是比较好计算
那如果是我们的金融资产
比如说黄金白银
对
然后我的这个BTC和ETH
那其实我们可以完全是基于统计关系
那这个也比较好解决
对
那我们看一下今天的案例
那我们就是把传统产业链的关系
这种传统的套利方式
如何和现有的这个机器学习的方式来结合
对
那传统方式关注的是什么
关注的是产业链关系
那我们看到玻璃和纯碱
那玻璃和纯碱
大家都比较清楚
这两个品种是很好套利的
那么我们可以看一下
它底层的产业链关系是什么
是纯碱是作为玻璃生产的
关键的原材料
原材料的话
我们就要看清楚了
基于产业链的这种物理关系
因为它是有联系的
我们每生产一吨平板玻璃
其实是大概是应该消耗
是0.2吨的纯碱
所以基于产业链关系的
传统考虑的方式呢
那我们的理论价差
其实是应该这么来算
那理论价差等于什么
理论价差等于是
玻璃的价格减去
纯碱的价格再乘以0.2
因为它是
我们每生产一吨玻璃
其实需要消耗0.2吨纯碱
那理论的价差
其实我们是应该这么来计算的
并不是说我们传统意义上理解的
那我玻璃直接减纯碱
或者是纯碱直接减玻璃
并不是这么粗暴的
那它还是有一些产业链关系的
那所以我们的系数呢
就是0.2
那为什么是0.2呢
是因为这种产业关系
是物理关系来产生
那这个我们是抹杀不掉的
我们遵循这个产业链的规律
那既然我们要和传统的产业链的
套利的方式相结合
那我们就要遵循这种规律
那我们再看一下
那基于这种理论的价差
那我们有没有其他的数学上的
其他的表现方式
那这里边呢
我罗列了四个
那也就是说
价差其实并不是我们传统意义上理解的
我就是单纯的A减B
或者是B减A
或者是A除B
或者是B除A
那其实我们还有很多别的方式
那第一个呢
其实就是刚才的那个理论的那个价差
我们称为简单价差
那第二个大家可以看一下
那其实我们设了一个N
这个N就是我们序列的一个长度
这个长度我们用它来计算什么呢
其实这个整个的一个过程
其实是一个对价差进行标准化的一个过程
大家看到没有
那我们这边是取MA
那我这边是算的是标准差
那用它来除它
那其实就是一个简单的一个标准化的一个过程
那这样处理价差其实也可以
那第三个方式呢
我们是用的是什么
我们是还是遵循这个0.2的这个规律
但是我们做了对数化的处理
上面的这个并不是说没有遵循0.2
而是我们把第一个
简单价差计算之后的结果
这个就是
第一个就是我们把它带过来了
其实这个价差的序列
代表是我们用上面的
简单的价差来做计算
它其实也是含了0.2
第三个其实就是
我们用了一个对数的方式来进行
那也是含着这个产业关系的
那最后一个呢
就是用读的方式
那也就是大家常用的
比如说减法
或者是图法来算价差
那图法的话
那我们也遵循这个产业链的
这个关系
那我们也乘上一个0.2
那大家可以看一下
那我们今天呢
其实是用的是最简单的这种方式
因为你既要遵循这个产业链的关系
那我们就用最简单的这种方式
就是用玻璃减去这个
纯碱乘以0.2的这种价差
对
那我们看一下
那它的这个价差
因为我们是取的是
从2020年一直到2025年
那为什么是2020年
这个因为我们的玻璃的数据
其实玻璃在国内上市
是比较早的
但是因为纯碱
是2019年的12月份
对才上市
所以12月份的数据
我们就通通的就不要了
对因为它是
19年12月份上市的
那所以呢
纯碱呢
我们就是从这个2021年的1月份开始
那为了和这个纯碱和玻璃对齐呢
所以呢
我们都统一了这个时间戳号
都是从2020年开始
那大家可以看到
那我们用简单的价差计算之后的
这个差值的这么一个
价差的这么一个趋势的
这么一个表达
可视化
对
那大家可以看到
那既然我们能把这个价差表达出来
那大家想没想过
那如果是这个样子的
那我是不是可以对这个价差
做趋势性的策略
而并不是说做均值回归的策略
大家有没有想过
那其实我们看到这个图
我们就可以把价差认为
是一个单独的标的
我们对价差进行趋势跟踪的策略
那沿着这个思路呢
那我们可以看一下
那这个价差本身的差
这个价差的差分以后呢
概率分布是什么样子
那我们看到了
那这个其实就是我们熟悉的
那我们进行对这个价差
基于价差进行价格行为的重采样
那为什么对它进行价格行为的重采样
大家因为上过咱们基础课的小伙伴会清楚
那比如说我们重采样的方式
其实有很多
那比如说这个基于成交量的
成交额的商的组合的
比如说是含有价格行为的
含有波动率的等等等等
那这个我们有很多种方式
那但是呢
在这个价差的数据上
我们没有这个成交量
成交额的这个数据
我们只有价格
我们只有价格数据
对那所以呢
我们只是对价格数据进行了计算
那所以价格数据
计算之后
那我们的可以对它进行价格行为的重采样
因为价格行为
我们只需要简单的这个价格数据就可以
那其他的比如说基于成交量啊
持仓量啊
那成交额
其实我们都已经都可以不用它了哈
那所以呢
针对只有价格的这种价差呢
那我们就进行基于价差的价格行为的重采样的
自定义轴的生成
那我们觉得啊
那这个轴其实还是可以的哈
因为这个其实就是我们课上讲的C1的
这个轴
那当然说我们也可以用
这个进阶课的X轴
直接把它压到
完全是正态分布
也可以
但是我们要试一下
我们用这种简单的
价格行为的C1的这个轴
即使它的这个峰值会高一些
也就意味着它的震荡
我们没有特别好的
给它降下来的时候
那当然说比时间轴要好很多
对
那像这种情况下
那我们是不是能够
把模型训练出来
对
那我们再看一下
那做完这个动作之后呢
那其实我们整个的这个Pipeline的设计
其实就已经很明显了
那聪明的小伙伴
可能大家都能够感受到
那我们其实后面要做什么了
那我整个把这个Pipeline
整个的这个步骤给大家罗列了出来
那我们是基于什么
基于产业链的关系
与这个我们机器学习相结合的
整个产业链整个生产线的设计
对那既然是产业链的关系的话呢
那我们就涉及到跟产业链关系的
这种价差的计算方式
那以及那我们机器学习
对价差的这种预测
那重点呢是两个哈
那价差的计算呢
那我们是依照产业链的关系来计算
那价差的预测呢
那我们是用机器学习来做的
那之后呢
我们做的是基于价差的
价格行为的重采
那刚才大家已经看到了
那个图我们是非常熟悉的
一个概率分布的图
那我们觉得这个图
是可以做趋势跟踪的
对那至少我们的那个
峰值比那个正态分布
高了一点点
那证明其实这个震荡
频次也不是那么多
对另外呢就是说
那我们可不可以
把我们传统意义上的
这种靠力的策略
我们其实就是变成了
趋势策略
对
其实这个是最重要的一个变换
我们跳出了传统的
比如说是基于这种斜整的
基于相关性的
基于这种copular
基于状态转移等等
其实我们完全就跟它没关系了
因为我们重点是什么
重点是我们可以做价差的这种预测
我们把套利可不可以变成趋势
是可以的
我们把套利的模型
就变成趋势的策略
对
之后
那我们对价差的预测
那是它是不是一个回归问题
那我回归问题的话
是不是我可以变成分类的问题
那也就是说回到了我们常用的这个Pipeline上
对那也就是说我们在我们现有基础课的
这个整个的生产线的基础上
我稍微改了一下
这个对数据的处理方式
那其实就可以用我们的现有的生产线
进行套利模型的这个
进行套利的这个整个的生产线的这个修改
那当然说价差的预测
我们可以是回归问题
可以是分类问题
那么回归也可以分类也可以
那这两个是完全能够转换的
那我们觉得分类可能比回归更容易来做
那当然说上过我们进阶课的小伙伴
会更熟悉回归
因为基础课的话只是讲了分类的这个方式
那下面呢就是牵扯到我们
Pipeline的这个趋势性标签的标注
那我们趋势性标签的标注
我们标注的是什么呢
标注的是价差
我们标注的是价差
我们把价差的这个最高最低
开盘收盘已经算出来了
对那我们对价差进行趋势性标签的标注
那后面呢我们对价差进行特征工程的
这个生成
那以及后面我们用降维
那无论是线性还是非线性
我们用降维的方式对特征进行存购
那后面是什么
后面是我们的模型的训练
模型的组合
那大家其实可以看下来
那我们是把这个基于产业链关系的
与机器学习的方式
核心是加差预测的这种方式相结合
那我们其实就是把套利的策略
整体变成了趋势性的策略
那当然说今天是时间关系有限
那后面可能我还会讲一下
比如说我们基于其他的
比如说基于Copular的模型
与机器学习的这种结合
还有可以是把这个状态转移
也可以和机器学习结合
生成新的另外的
基于机器学习的
这个生产线的设计
今天主要讲的是基于产业链
与这个机器学习的这种结合
所以大家可以看到
这个就是我们整个完整的
一套全新的一个套利框架的
生产线的一个设计
对那后面呢
其实就是刚才我们以上来
给大家呈现的这个图哈
对这个是玻璃和纯碱
那我们交易的时候呢
其实比如说我们做多也好
做空也好
其实是同时来下这个纯碱和玻璃的
那其实就是我们产生信号
比如说产生1产生0
那其实就是一个就是做多玻璃
做空这个纯碱的
另外的一个呢
就是做空玻璃
做多纯减
那其实这个都很简单的
和我们原有的这个拍面栏相结合
OK
那这个今天呢
就是主要讲的这个
完全不同的这个
套利的生产线的框架
对
那上过咱们课程的小伙伴们
会非常容易好理解
那我们其实就是通过这个
重点就是通过数据的处理
如何依据这种产业链的关系
那把这种关系呢
呈现到我们的这个数据处理的这个部分
那我们再把这个架叉处理之后的这个架叉呢
都以这个架叉作为我们的这个目标
我们把架叉作为一个单独的一个标的
来进行模型训练
其实是这么一个思路哈
OK那看看大家
有没有什么问题哈
我们可以那个直接出入
或者是这个这个上卖也可以哈
我一鸣老师先休息一下
感谢一鸣老师
然后我因为今天
因为我发现有很多咱们是老朋友
也有一些新的小伙伴
然后我刚开场的时候
其实忘了跟大家介绍一鸣老师
这个也是为了之后
待会大家可以抓紧这个时间
有什么问题
也可以直接问到一鸣老师
如果说现在目前研究的过程当中的话
一鸣老师
他应该算是我们圈内的一个技术大牛了
一个前辈了
对因为他是我的老师
他们以前在美国的同事
那目前呢他们的机构呢是在海外
他们主要做的市场呢也是在海外市场
然后呢他们就是机构是叫DCP Mother Oracle
就现在目前的管理规模是不到13亿美金吧
对所以说英明老师呢也是作为机构的联畅
因为是这么多年一直在做技术
我们也都是一帮做技术的人
所以就比较简单
我们也不喜欢搞太多title在身上
所以呢大家做技术的人呢
我们在一起呢就直接就简单直接
咱们就聊怎么样可以让模型做得更好
怎么样可以让咱们的盈利做得更好
所以接下来呢
大家有问题的话
可以抓紧今天的时间
然后有问题都可以直接问到一米老师
包括我们今天有一些
可能是刚认识不久的小伙伴
然后呢
想要看到一米老师之前的一些公开课的内容
可以再去我的那个
哔哩哔哩的那个主页上面去看一看
好吧
OK
那大家接下来有问题
可以直接上来提问
或是在评论区打字也OK的
好吧
因为之前的我有非常详细的
讲过我们机器学习的
整个PAPLAN的一个视频
大家可以看看那个视频
对那个视频
其实看完之后
可能对今天的这个视频
理解起来会更容易
因为有很多的图
其实我都是没有表现出来
因为可能更多的是
我们为了给我们
上过课的小伙伴
提供了一个
除了趋势策略以外的
这个套利策略的这么一种方式
对
老师能听清吗
可以OK
老师我听过您那个基础课
然后有一个就是
就是比较基础的问题想跟你
因为当时没听清楚
然后那个就是您
不管是这个堂课
还有上次课
那个就是在做自定义轴的时候
上次课是用的那个成交
成交额吧
对吧
那个成交额的那个自定义的轴
那个成交额有一个问题
就是您做那个成交额的时候
有一个初始值
那您初始值
比如说您上次用的是罗文刚
那比如说我用股指期货
您那个初始值该怎么定义
就是怎么如何
那个初始值是怎么
那个最初那个参数是怎么定的
预值吗
对预值是这样的
对预值呢
因为我们是用我们的那个预值
来控制我们的交易频率
这个交易频率呢
是因为我们是自定义嘛
自定义的话
也就是意味着我们的频率
可以可以任意的放大或者是缩小
因为目的是打破这个时间轴的每一个k线
或者叫每一个bar内部的信息密度不均匀的这么一个问题
因为我们都知道时间轴是完全不具有统计特性
对那我们在进行铜彩样的自定义轴生成之后呢
让我们的这个分布呢
其实更接近于正态
那这是第一
第二呢是让我们的这个
就是每一个bar内部的信息密度相对的更均匀
对那至于说是那个预值呢
一定要是我的建议是
大家舒服的交易频率就可以
对比如说你舒服的交易频率是这个
比如说比如说每天两到三次
或者是很长一些
或者是更短一些都没都没有关系
对用我们的预值来控制这个交易密度
对但是呢国内的股指是有一个
最致命的一个问题
因为股指的日内平仓的手续费是非常高的
对这是第一
那第二呢
就是说是机构呢
其实用在股指上面
基本上都是做空
很少有做多的这种行为
那为什么机构做空
做空的多
因为它其实是
比如说我们选一揽子股票的时候
或者是做这个ETF轮动的时候
它有一些中性的策略
或者叫这个止增的这个策略
它需要把那个beta来对冲
对冲掉
那所以呢
它要在股指上面有做空的这种需求
所以基于这两点
第一是它日内平仓的手续费比较高
个人做的话
基本上都是以日内锁仓为主
第二个就是因为机构都是在做空的比较多
所以股指它的价格呈现出来
可能大家看到就相对比较诡异一些
对那所以呢
那你如果是针对股指来做
这个交易频率特别高的
这种策略的话
那其实在这个实际落地的时候
那其实还是有一点点困难的
那比如说你是锁仓
那当然说锁仓是一种方式了
那第二个方式呢
其实就是把我们的这个交易频率放大
对那当然说这个你也可以不做股指
可以直接对宽积的
国内宽积的ETF
进行这个模型的训练
只是你做空的
那个信号就变成了
那个平方信号
那个我大概听明白了
我理解不知道对不对啊
就是说那个就是初始的那个size
您的那个以前的课程用的是
比如说三万一啊
或三万几
你这个可以灵活的去定
自己定一个
自己的频率自己的定一个
然后按照这个来一个一个生成bar
有的可能那个bar
您定的那个位置
针对您的课程来说
那个数值可能定的
可能就是相当于
天的dayline的那个
day的kline是吧
就是那个频率
你也可以定成小时的
那个级别的是吧
没错没错
就是至少就是
第一呢
就是说我们要看这个标的
对
那因为除了股指以外呢
其他的商品期货
或者是那个crypto的话
其实就没有这个问题了
因为股指期货是比较特殊的
就是说你日内交
交易会比较麻烦
那除了股指期货以外
那其实日内交易都还是可以的
那所以就是定一个
自己相对比较舒服的
这么一个交易频率就可以了
然后就是另一个就是说
在这个舒服的交易频率
初始制定了以后
就是能够在那个
就是能更接近于政态分布
就自己不断的去测
能接近政态分布
然后再
然后才能定下来
这个最终的那个自定义轴
是吗
其实也不用太接近于正态
对因为我们进阶课会讲
这个如何把它
其实就是完全正态
那基础课的话
其实我们只要是同等频率的
这个交易频率
你只要是比时间轴
更接近于正态
那其实就是代表
你已经有贡献了
因为你至少是
第一呢
是你办案内部的信息密度
相对已经均匀
对就是统计特性更强嘛
那第二呢
其实就是你比那个
就是timeline
就是那个时间轴的这个震荡品质会更低嘛
那你肯定会会会比他的这个峰值要低
那已经是有共享
对所以也不用让他
就是完全接近于正态
其实也可以
你看我们现在的这个轴
其实也没有用那个
那个就是完全接近正态的轴
然后我们就是简单价格行为
然后来生成
其实也可以
对那这个其实就比时间轴要好很多
您这个12345是什么意思
12345是窗口期
一个窗口期
因为差分
两个窗口期
到五个窗口期
好好好
谢谢老师
王老师好
我这边想问个问题
可以吗
OK
理解
因为之前课程的问题
我觉得大家都有趣
在底下问比较好
我就问一下
就是这堂公开课的问题
因为不是趋势性
我可以理解为
我做多架差
然后当方向反转的时候
我是相当于平走的方向调换吗
比如说如果价差走阔的话
我价差不是定义玻璃减纯减成立年二吗
那我这个价差走阔的话
那我相当于是做多玻璃做空纯减吗
是这么理解的吧
没错没错
它的一
对对对
那如果说它那个方向出发的时候
那相当于我就
不是平常就是两边直接对调做
就相当于做多纯减做空玻璃
是这么个意思
没错没错
对对对
那就没有这个不持仓的这个情况
或者说
我知道了
会有不持仓的情况
因为我们模型组合之后
肯定有不持仓
因为还是会回到趋势上
那你趋势上
比如说你加差产生震荡的时候
我们不知道怎么做了
那模型出的那个
你看我们的这个
这里边其实也有不持仓
我们是差不多是4比1
800多次持仓
然后不到200次的不持仓
那基本上就是4比1的这么一个
这个就是两个模型组合
然后我还没有做三个
这个就是为了给大家简单的看一眼
大家设计完以后
肯定都会比我的这个会更好
对因为这个时间太赶了
对就没有太那个啥
这个的前提是需要这个
品种本身有协整关系吧是吧
协整关系也没有
因为如果是你是做
它没有协整关系
其实也没有
其实也可以做
对你看好
那我们比如说
做这个
我们做这个模型的这个
比如说你找到了两个品种
那你找到了两个品种
可能你不知道
比如说我们用DBSCAN
找到了两个品种
它之间有没有这种关系
其实我们不知道
因为协整呢
其实是简单的线性关系
对那如果用DBSCAN的话呢
那其实经济意义上呢
我们没有办法解释它
对所以呢
我们其实是能够做的
对
但是你如果是要这两个品种
它为什么有这种关系
那么这个解释性就比较弱了
对
就是可以做
但是我们不知道是什么原因
对
也可以获利
这个其实是
现在比较主流的这么一种方式
对
好的
谢谢老师
谢谢
OK
一鸣老师
我想问一下
OK
先问吧
行吧
一鸣老师我也有个问题
就是刚刚提到的
就是一些剧烈的方式
然后这些剧烈的方式的话
我们有没有必要从资产的逻辑上
给它一些赋予一些意义
还是说只需要从数学上
给它验证出来就行
两个维度
当然说我们可以对它进行相应的约速
比如说我打到这一页
比如说我们特征可以是基于什么
比如说是波动
自相关技术指标等等
当然说我们也可以给它其他的这种约速
对那也就是说我是希望你能稍微有一点点的
经济的意义
然后呢另外呢是我们人工可能筛选不到的
靠出我们认知范围的这个品种
对这个是可以的
就说我为什么问这个问题
就是因为有很多剧烈算法
就比如说db scan
因为它本身对某些超单数那个比较敏感
但如果你没有这种资产
这种金融上的意义的话
有可能就会导致
就是你真的试盘的时候
有可能会效果不太好
没错
对会有这个问题
那当然其实我们都可以通过一些参数
以及我们给到的一些特征
那种这些参数和特征
对它进行相应的一个约束
对如果大家对这个感兴趣的话
然后我后面也可以有时间的话
我对这个也可以掌材
再给大家再详细讲一下
对这个还是蛮好玩的
好的谢谢一鸣老师
我没问题了
OK
老师我想问一下
就是你比如说有的品种
这个比如说橡胶啊这种
它本身是农产品
但是它又在那个工业的产业
然后还有这个
就是比如说尿素啊
它本身是工业品
但是它会用在这个农产品里
就是说如果它这个
就是这个品种
它会涉及到多个板块
这种的话
剧烈算法或者说是
就是用什么方法去处理
它会比较好一些呢
如果是用传统的这种协整性
或者是copular的方式呢
可能会对两个品种之间的
这种要求会更高
那如果呢
我们把它变成了我们的
就是这个方式
就是把它变成了
我们价差预测的这种方式呢
那其实呢
就是会有一定的包容性
然后你可以试想一下
假设咱们不用DP-SCAN
对就是我们就随随便说
比如说黄金和猪肉
我可不可以
其实可以就什么都什么都可以
对然后就什么A和B
其实都可以
那我们主要
就是那我们通过另外的维度来看
适不适合
可能就是不是余限于迪比斯坦了
对你试想一下
那我们是可以把套利变成趋势的
没错吧
对那趋势是什么呢
趋势
然后我因为我一上来
为什么要讲这一页
那我们趋势赚的是什么的钱
赚的是惯性的钱
那也就是说我们的
其实是它的这种标的价格变化
是不是存在这种正的自相关性
对那假设说我们随便
我们也不用DPC看
我们就是随便抽了两个这个标的
那两个标的
那我们来相减或者是相除以后
我们要看它能不能把它变成趋势的策略
那其实我们可以换一个角度
那你既然是要做趋势
那关键就是自相关性
那假设我们随便选了两个标点
那我们减完之后或者除完之后
我们看它的这个价差或者是价比
有没有自相关性其实就可以
对我不知道我讲的
就是清不清楚
对就是因为我们可以换一个角度
我们就是不是站在套利的角度上
因为套利的角度可能大家永远会是想的都是相关性
想的都是那个协整性
对
然后那我们跳出来
那我们把它变成趋势
变成趋势呢
那我们赚的是市场惯性的钱
那惯性的钱呢
那它的这个差
它的这个比
那我们检测一下
比如说我们用这个DW
用这个ACD
用那个ACF
对
然后我们去看它自相关性有没有
那假设它有自相关性的话
那我们觉得OK
那我就是能拿趋势模型来干你
其实就可以了
这个是我想表达的
也是今天想给大家
也是今天想给大家传递的
一个重点的一个思维框架
老师我就想就是
你看就是我也看了一些书
就是说它这个就是风控这一块
就是它是用那个相关性比正去做
还是用那个HRP那个方法去做
就是说我就是感觉
他们这些方法都是
没有考虑到这种
这个品种它其实跟
多个类其实都会有关系
就是说
没错没错
我有问一下AI
他说可能用图模型
但是我不是特别确定这一块
就是怎么落地或者是能不能可行
这种我不是特别确定
因为我想就是对这个
相关性就是他
他去测度的时候
它应该会就是不是两两之间的
或者说是它有没有什么
更好的一种测度的方法
或者管理的方法
这一块就是
想这一块
其实还有一个思路
还有一个思路
就是我们不见得是
两个简单的标的来进行套利
或者是用我们的方式进行这种趋势
就把套利变成趋势
我们可以站在更高的维度来想
就是说那我即使某一个品种
可能和其他的很多品种之间
其实都有关系的话
那我是不是可以做
两大类的这类的指数
比如说我把这一类的这个品种
把它指数化
对那我把另一大类的品种
我也把它指数化
然后呢最后呢
用两个指数之间来做这种套利
那当然是
那当然说如果假
假设两个指数
本身我们就可以做
去实行策略的话
那其实我们就不用再专门的为它设计套利的策略了
那如果你的趋势型策略
因为趋势比这个就是传统的这个套利
其实这个容量会更大
对因为我们要知道我们不是为了套利而套利
对然后因为今天的课
我是希望给大家传递一个
就是转变的一个思路或者叫思维框架
对大家可以沿着这个框架去去想
因为我们本身不是为了套利而套利
那如果能这个本身这个指数啊
这个品种能做趋势的话
那其实我们还是做做趋势更容易哈
对那当然说就是刚才你提到的那个问题
那某一个标的和很多标的
其实他都都有这种关联的话
那其实我们就可以用触化的这个方式
用指数和指数之间去套利
对那这是也是一个思路
谢谢老师
OK我刚才看到这个这个这个聊聊天记录里面
刚才提到了那个0.2哈
对这个思路没有没有问题哈
反着算
因为我还有一就是这个0.2是基于产
是产业链关产业链的这个关系计算出来的
我们也可以反着算哈
这个是没没错的
因为我这里边已经写了哈
那如果产业链关系的话
如果是工业品农产品等等
那我们是可以基于物理关系来生成哈
因为它它是上下游或者是它是可替代等等
那我们是有这个物理上的这个常识的
对那这个参数是我们能够估出来的
但是呢如果我们想要它更多数学上精确的话
其实这个0.2也好
0.3也好
我们可以反着推
就是像刚才我们那小伙伴在这个打的那个字
对那我们可以反着把它推出来
这是没有问题的
对那这个其实就是我想说的
如果是金融资产套利的话
那如何来套
那其实是我们反着来算细数
对
那比如说是黄金和白银
那它两个没有物理关系
对
那我们不知道它两个有什么关系
那另外呢
其实就是还有这个
比如说BTC和ETH
那这两个更没有什么物理关系
那它纯金融资产
那我们只是基于统计
来反着来算这个数
对
这个是没有问题
老师我还想问一个问题
就是我您基础课的那个pipeline
那个上次上次那个公开课
说的那个做趋势的罗恩刚的那个
我看到那个罗恩刚的那个回撤
只有八个点
用那个DIF9
然后您看您这次的这个做套利的
按道理回撤应该更小
我看也有八个点
这个背后的原因
您能分析一下吗
这个其实你不用太关注
这个回撤的具体的绝对值
这个绝对值其实不用太关注
因为我们算那个系数的时候
其实都是没有加杠杆的
那个RB
其实我们用那个系数是0.25
那这个系数
然后我们是依照那个玻璃
和那个就是纯碱的那个系数来算的
其实这个数我们稍微调一下
然后它就可以变得很小
但是唯一不变的是什么
唯一不变的其实是这个卡码值
这卡码是不变的
对
我建议是更关注卡码
这个因为我们稍微
稍微加杠杆上去
它这个数值就会很大
在减杠杆的话
这个数值就很小
你不用关注它的这个绝对值
对
你关注它的这个卡码
因为卡码是比例
就是你那个数值怎么变的
卡码是不会变的
对
这个卡码是4.58
就关注这个就可以了
也就是说
您那个楼文刚
那个是不是
没有加杠杆的情况下
那个是没有加杠杆
完全没有加杠杆
其实就是不是满仓的情况下是吗
用了差不多
就没有加杠杆
就意味着只用了八分之一的钱
只用了八分之一的钱
但是收益呢
是按照百分之百算的
比如说你是一千万
一千万的话呢
我们理论上的只用了一百多万
比如说一百二十五万是八分之一嘛
那理论上是一千万
只用了一百多万的钱
但是呢你不能按一百多万的
那个保证金来算你的收益
那你按那个算的话
其实已经翻了很多倍了哈
那所以呢我们是按照那个货值
按照一千万的货值
来计算我们的那个收益
其实保证金才占了八分之一
对是在没有加杠杆的情况下
那您这个意思就是说
套利是用满仓来算的是吧
没有这个也是完全没有加杠杆
对都是没有加杠杆
还有一个问题
就比如说
按照您当前的这个pipeline的话
比如说我不用的这个自定义轴
就用传统的时间轴
然后但是有比较好的因子
用您的打标签的方法
或者做预测
也可以啊
也可以是吧
可以的没问题
对然后但是时间轴的话呢
会比这个
会比从彩样的轴会差一些
对但是不是说不能用
对会差一些
另外呢就是
还有一个关键的一个地方
就是在交叉验证的时候
如果你是时间轴的话呢
因为你不是
因为重采样轴的话呢
是比时间轴更接近于ID
更接近于这个独立同分布
那所以在训练的时候呢
我交叉验证的时候
我们敢用分层去做交叉验证
对但是呢你时间轴的话
你的交叉验证呢
因为你是完全不是ID的
跟ID完全就没关系嘛
对那所以呢
你就要必须回到这个
按照时间规矩的这种交叉验证的方式
对就这个需要注意一点点
那可以用K折来代替吗
K折也不行
因为你时间轴的话
就是最好就是按照时间顺序
这就是把这个整个那个
那个训练级拆成K段来
一个一个的测行吗
对你就是你是打成了N折
比如说你打了5折
打了这个10折
对这个是没有问题的
但不是那个Kfold的那种方式
Kfold因为它打乱之后
它是前后是随机排列的
因为你时间的话
对你是要严格
你可以拆分成五折或者是十折
但是一定要按照时间顺序算
对就是切成五段嘛
把这个时间轴
对对对
但是你如果重采样以后呢
你是比时间轴更接近于ID
所以我们就改这个分层来算
就是把那个测试数据分成
那个测试级和验证级那种是吧
这个不是这个分层
是交叉验证的一种方式
谢谢老师
看看大家还有没有什么问题
我想问一下
您觉得您这套工作流程
它用在跨期效率上面的话
会有效果吗
效果会怎样
因为跨期效率
它可能有个特点
就是数据相对于
跨平均效率
和这个假差的区别
要更加平稳
是不是就有点没有必要去做
没错没错没错
对然后因为我刚才也强调了
不是为了套利而套利
因为今天是给大家传递一个
全新的一种思维框架
然后如果是近期和远期套的话
因为我们本身是不这么来做
因为我们认为远期的流动性
不是那么好
因为我们的资金量比较大
对所以有一些像是个人
比较做的方式
其实我们都没有在做
对
然后呢
这个坦率讲
我没有试过
所以我不太好说
对
就近期和远期
然后但是呢
我个人觉得
因为远期的流动性
不是那么好
它容不下很多的
这种资金
对
所以像这类的策略
我们都没有尝试
对
明白明白
好的
那我想再问一个
就是实践中的一个问题
就是你怎么去解决
两个品种之间的套利
如果它没有交易所的
那种
它去套利的实用的话
或者跨品种套利的确定
那罚点或者说
没办法同时成交
那怎么来去解决这个问题
我这是个问题吗
你是说是跨市场套利吗
就是两个不同的市场
对对
但是我可能
我看到这个机会
但是我实际做进去的时候
我们就会面临很大的罚点
因为大家都趁到了这个机会
没错没错没错
没错
对
我们曾经做过这个
这个跨市场的这个我们曾经做过
这个稍微有一点点麻烦
这个需要我们的模型
就是有一个更宽泛的这么一个容错的这么一个机制
就是说是相当于是我们允许多大范围内出错
那我们在回测的时候
是把这个范围内的出错
我们也要算进去
就是假设说
如果我们现实和我们的这个
这个backtesting的这个两者的差异
残差特别大的话
那我们觉得这个就没有办法做了
即使我们放的很宽
我们也没有办法做
那如果呢
现实中的是在我们放宽的这个范围之内
那我们觉得
那我们允许这个错误存在
那这个是可以的
对
因为这个跨市场是
是因为有这个时间的问题
有这个交易磨损的问题
它会是比较麻烦
另外我们的跨市场的经验
其实还要有现货的这种支撑
那最早我们是做过
这个上海和RME的
然后我们香港那边
其实和国内
还有这个贸易公司
来用这个现货来
就是来有这个现货上的支撑
那个可能需要
更复杂的这个框架
并不是说纯是纯跨
就是纯跨市场的这个行为
那假设你手里有现货
那你就是比如说你和这个
Glamco 托克 莱宝 三井 完红
像这类的大的国际的贸易商的话
那如果有现货交易的话
其实你在金融市场上套利的话
其实相对来讲会更从容一些
对 这是我们的一个经验
OK 我看大家提到了这个
哎一鸣老师哎啊你听见了啊
我这边想问一个问题
就是呃我们在做那个多模型组合的时候
就是对结果多个模型进行组合的时候
他其实回测只看回测结果其实会
效果其实会好一点
但因为我们是做趋势的吗
呃他可能会让他最后的这个标签
就更加的片段化
就没有那么连续
然后这个时候就呃做期货交易的话
就会带来很多信号反转的问题
然后就会产生比较大的一个
金餐
比如说平均的这些手续费
它带来的收益
可能抵消不了它这个手续费
然后其实在试判的时候
它其实效果
反而其实还会变得更差
是这样的
我知道你的这个问题
对
然后因为之前也有小伙伴问
它这是几个维度
第一就是我们不能是这种
幸存者偏差
比如说我们选模型
那时候因为我经常讲
就是因为过你河
其实分很多种
那比如说我们标签
也有可能过你河
我们训练级也有可能过你河
我们的这个测试级
也有可能过你河
那每一个环节
我们全有抑制过你河的这种方式
那比如说测试级
为了防止测试级过你河的话
也就是说你
第一呢你不能选择
就是你完全看上去
就是最好的那几个模型
那我一直强调是这个
那第一呢
你至少是整个你的
比如说从这个低维到高维
整个训练完之后呢
那我们要看一眼
你所有的这个训练模型
是不是相对的这个曲线
相对比较一致
那如果它相对比较一致的情况下的
那我们是选择维度更低的这个模型吧
那这是第一哈
对那第二点呢
就是说你说到的这个组合完之后
打破了它的这种连续性
这个是有这么一个问题
因为假设说我们是一个组合
比如说我们两个模型进行了一个组合
或者是三个模型进行了一个组合
那这是一个维度
那其实我的建议呢
是我们每一个品种呢
可能有很多轴
那每一个轴呢
我们有N个组合
那我们是同时在跑
那同时在跑的时候呢
那其实它相互之间
会有一个大的这么一个对冲
那这个经验呢
其实告诉我们
那基本上以这种方式来做的情况下呢
那第一呢
是增加了很多不持仓的时间段
对
就是增加了增加的不持仓的时间段呢
其实更多的是它是连续的
对
它并不是零零散散的
它是连续的
对
那这是第一
第二呢
就其实就是让我们知道了更多的
就是类似于国内有一个说法
就是趋势的那个中段嘛
比如说那个头和尾
可能我都不要了
那我要的是那个中段
更多的是中段的这种连续性
那这是我们的这个经验
那并不是说是我
只是两个模型组合完以后
那我就跑
那其实这种情况
其实也可以
那但是如果你是多个轴
多个组合下来之后
其实效果会更好
对那这是建议
那这是轴这里
采用不同的轴
然后其他
比如说一马克夫那边的参数
选不同参数
然后最后再选不同模型
这样去做组合是吗
就多个维度去做组合
没错没错
也就是说你不同的轴
然后呢每一个轴呢
下面呢至少要
就是你其实
你至少要有一组嘛
那如果你是两组
或者三组
其实也可以哈
对
但是就是
不建议特别多
或者叫不建议特别多的模型
进行组合
比如说你是十个模型
甚至因为我们测试过
我们最多测试过
100个模型进行组合
其实那个
其实也有点夸张
对
因为我们就是看
那个边界在哪里
想算出来一个边界
但是最后呢
我们觉得
其实这个简单的
两个组合
三个组合
其实效果
其实就已经可以
对
那我在选
选这个模型组合的时候
我是
像你刚才说的
不应该选
比如说Karma
它是最高的两个
就是
但是它的走势
可能并不是一样的
那么这个时候
这两个模型
其实不适合做组合
第一我们
当然比如说你看排序的话
也可以
因为我们每一个模型
训练完之后
其实它都会有
它相应的排序
排序只是我们
就是一个依据之一
最重要的是
我们整个训练完
一组模型下来
我们要看一组模型
是不是它的效果都还可以
就除了最小的那几个维度
因为最小的维度
是不可能去训练好的
对
然后呢
就是说除了最小的那几个维度之后呢
就基本上它的趋势性都还差不多
那像这
像这种时候呢
我们其实选维度更低的
对
不见得是选这个卡码最高的
那就是那如果我训练
比如说我是一共是100维
那得有100个模型吗
那那他这100个模型里面
他其实就可能不是像您说的
他每个效果其实都都还好
它可能就会出现
比如说有的很
有的就是三点几
有的
然后还有可能
还有一半是零点几之中
那么
其实这个
就不建议
在这里面
做筛选来来用
是吗
因为它可能
每个维度
它的效果不好
不均匀
我明白你的意思
第一呢
其实是
其实是这个
用不到这么高的
这个维度
其实正常情况下
因为你维度过高的话呢
就会造成
这个对模型的约束会更多
也就产生过礼盒的这么一个问题
所以呢
就是基本上我们会算一个开值出来吧
那比如说你用PCA降维的话
就线性降维的话
比如说你先算一个开值
你减去噪音与共线性的问题
你对特征进行重构了嘛
进行重构之后
它多少维能够表达
我们99.99%的这种信息嘛
那比如说你是40就可以了
那你40就可以的话
你没有必要训练到100枚嘛
对
因为那里我现在没有用那个PCA
就是我有用其他网络去做
对
VAE包括这种
对抗网络去做
可以啊
对就是也可以
但是呢
这种方式建议呢
是依照PCA的维度来做参考
因为你否则
管看那个MSE的值呢
是没有依据的
因为我讲那个自编码器的时候
也讲过
因为你看那个MSE的值
它越小的话就证明其
那其实我们那个在
在在在那个解码的时候
我们恢复到原数据的时候
它的损失会更小吗
对但是呢
就是MSE假设说
损失特别大的时候
也不代表它不能用
但是呢它维度很低
其实我们也可以选它
对那那多少为作为上限呢
其实可以参考PCA
就还是按PCA的有效信息
99%的维度
作为用其他网络的参考
没错
其实就可以
谢谢老师
OK
刚才小伙伴提到
LSTM
因为LSTM
其实不太建议用
因为最终的模型
我们建议还是用决策数
因为决策数的解释性更强
就尽可能的少用这种实用网络
但是LSTM其实作为最终模型训练的话
效果会非常烂
对这是第一
第二呢
其实它对于这种金融的这种结构化数据的话
其实支持的不是那么好
对那所以呢
我们一般都是在用这个
在做特征或者是降维的时候
我们会把这个LSTM嵌进来
对比如说我们用VAE
或者是用那个循环自编码器的时候
我们会用那个LSTM嵌进来
然后用它隐藏层
输出的这个信息
给到我们最初的这个
就是最终的这个模型
作为输入
对
那直接用这个LSTM
这个千万不要这么做
对
另外呢
有小伙伴算就是
刚才提到的
第一相关的这种组合
这个是没有问题的
当然说我们也不建议
用那个皮尔逊
因为我课上一直强调
就是说你相关性的话
一般都是二平方和皮尔逊
但是这个不建议用
然后我们建议用
是基于质的这种方式
因为譬如训和二平方
还是有正态的
这种正态分布的假设的
这个不同模型组合
可以不持仓
不同的轴怎么
不同轴的那个组合
它是自然形成的
这种不持仓
对
是自然形成的这种不持仓
因为我们下单的时候
有两种方式
对
那一个就是
老师可以继续问一下吗
可以
就比如说我现在A轴有一个信号
然后比如说它是买入
然后五分钟之后
B轴又有一个信号
它是卖出
这样子是
是什么样子的情况
怎么样处理
A轴买入
是这样的
因为我刚才正好想讲
因为这种仓位
其实有两种管理方式
那一种呢
是就是各做各的
比如说他做多
他做空
然后他不持仓
就是各做各的
那还有一种呢
是我们统一
比如说有一个信号出来了
我们先不做任何操作
我们先看我们的这个头寸
就用不用换
对
那假设说正好是A组合
就是有一个是做多了
那B组合有
然后有一个做空
对
那其实是
相当于是我们把那个
就是多出来的这个头寸来下
因为有的时候
它这个时间点出来之后
然后其实我们是不用操作的
对
它的那个信号
其实就相互抵消掉了
相当于我们没有操作
对
所以这是一个方式
因为我们要减少这种过度交易
对
我不知道
就是这个不同的组合
它是其实在同一个时间
下出的信号
然后它们进行互相抵消
如果你是同一个轴的话
那肯定是同一个时间
对
那你至少在这个维度上
你可以进行一个判断
对
就是如果有相互抵消掉的
这种信号
其实你的仓位是可以不变的
对
就是你多出来的
那如果是不同的轴的话
不同的轴
这个就没有办法了
就不同的轴
这个你就是必须要
必须是要执行了
明白了
我看Uni是请问
宽集ETF上可以应用这套
宽集可以啊
宽集是没有问题的
对宽集的话
就是相当于是我们
把做空的这个信号
就是所有的流程全一样
所有的流程全一样
就是做空的这个信号
就是变成平仓了
对就是你出空的信号
就是代表是平仓了
对另外宽集呢
就是要符合国内的
国内的交易规则
就是你日内是没有办法去平仓的
所以我们需要把周期稍微变大
另外就是这种方式是两种应用
一种是你直接对宽级的ETF
或者是其他的
比如行业的ETF
或者是其他的ETF进行模型的训练
你单独就成为一个趋势跟踪的
这么一个趋势型的
这么一个策略了
那第二个用途呢
是假设你在宽积上
做了这个趋势型的训练之后呢
然后与这个你的个股的
基于这个宽积的成分股的
截面的策略结合起来
把它作为你的那个
截面的那个则实
对 也就是说
做不做呢
由这个A模型
就是趋势型的这个模型
来出信号
它让我们做的时候呢
那我们那边再去
去盘序去
对
就是它时序的模型
决定我们做不做
而截面的那个策略呢
做成分个股的策略呢
是决定我们做哪些
对
就是这个有两个用途
老师您好
你好
我想我刚才有个同学问那个
他说模型组合
打破了交易的连续性
这块我其实没太理解
就是说他说算上手续费
可能是不合算的
我不太理解
就是是不是说
比如说我一个模型
本来是开多的几套
突然间反转了
但是被人开空了
那我应该先平再反向开空吧
是不是这个过程
要交两次手续费导致的
就是我可能没太理解这个过程
不是这个
他说的不连续
是因为我们有不吃仓的时候
有不吃仓的时候
更多的是在震荡的时候不吃仓
对
那有的时候我们希望
比如说我们做多
然后中间可能有一段波段
这是咱们回头看
因为当我们交易的时候
我们是没有办法知道
它的这个趋势的连续性的
那假设说我们回头看的话
那我们希望我们一直持有多
对它震荡的时候呢
我们也不变
然后呢我们一直持多
那如果中间我们变的话呢
其实这个连续性就打断了
他说的是这个意思
对就会相应的增加
我们一部分的这种手续费
因为你有平仓的这个过程吧
对是这个意思
谢谢老师
OK
OK好
那看看大家如果没有其他的问题的话
我看几点
将近一个小时40分钟
OK那谢谢大家的这个关注
那我们后面也会有更多的这个主题分享
来和大家来讲
辛苦英明老师了
然后呢后续呢小伙伴们
比如说大家想要在系统的去学习到这一套Pipeline的话
因为其实量化
其实我知道
我不知道大家现在是在机构做
还是说个人做
就如果是在机构
会更明显的能感受到
其实量化最重要的
就是在我们设计策略的时候
就要站在整体的一个生产线的
一个统筹的视角去设计
因为就像我修房子一样
我现在要修一个房子
我至少先得知道
我每一步先要做什么吧
那很多时候
大家可能今天查到这个资料
我去学这个
明天查到那个资料
我去学那个
可能学了很长时间
其实这个整个系统
也都是零零散散的
包括这个也是我们之前线下课
很多个人在座的小伙伴们
大家交流下来
我觉得最明显的一个问题
所以后期如果说大家想往职业量化
这个方向发展的话呢
那如果说想要系统的学习
学习这套Pipeline
那也可以来听到英明老师的线下课
那当然就跟我联系就可以了
包括今天呢
我也听到很多很熟悉的声音
也都是咱们之前的小伙伴们
对
然后呢
那OK
今天的话
看看大家还没有什么问题
如果没问题的话
咱们就今天先到这里结束了
后面大家有任何问题都可以随时交流
随时沟通
好吗
谢谢大家
OK咱们下次再见
也辛苦英语老师了
谢谢大家
好的再见